in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Jacob
and Jennifer are with us hey how are ya
about yourself
better than a deserve welcome are y'all
from Dallas Texas welcome to Nashville
and here to do your debt free scream
yeah absolutely I love it I love it how
much have you guys paid off we have paid
off ninety three thousand dollars in
twenty two months good job making what
kind of money we started off making
ninety thousand and we now we make about
a hundred way to go what do y'all do for
a living after you I work at a software
company mm-hmm and I work at a feed
store oh very cool good for you guys
excellent so ninety-three thousand
dollars that right man what kind of debt
was this it was a mixture of some
different things Dave so we started out
with some student loans and then bought
some cars on top of that before we
decided get our finances in order so
what happened 22 months ago this started
this process well Jennifer can tell a
story better not can so after we got
married my parents recommended that we
take Financial Peace University how long
ago did you get married in September of
2013 so a little over two years okay so
we started financial piece in October of
2013 and we before that we made some
really bad decisions and bought
brand-new cars because we were very
entitled and thought that was what we
deserved immediately after college and I
think deep down we knew after we started
taking the class we would regret that
decision so we made sure to do that
before we take that's like eating
chocolate cake right before going on a
diet the decisions that we made but we
that really doubled our debt and gave us
a lot to work for but we just powered
through and got gizelle intense and
knocked it out as quick as we could very
cool very cool that's a lot to pay off
it was two years I mean you haven't done
anything you've had no life right a lot
of board games they sell the cars would
you pay them off we paid them off you
kept absolutely
we're very stubborn people that's ok you
did you did fine it's
that's a lie that I mean you busted this
in two years 22 months that's pretty
amazing people had to be making fun of
you oh definitely oh yeah yeah we have
the envelope and I have some envelopes
in my wallet designate how much money I
could spend and all that good stuff in
that yeah people always give me a hard
time about that yeah guys at work or
really weren't ragging on you about that
I'm sure yeah absolutely
when people call us crazy we take it as
a compliment absolutely very flattering
weird because normals broke yeah where
does a good thing and you need three
thousand dollars in new year's but you
gotta feel good we do we're very excited
you got a free I miss you gotta feel
like light like you not got like you got
weight off your neck or something man
that's amazing I mean wow and here's the
cool thing I mean you only been married
two years if you if you couldn't do this
you guys can do anything yes sir because
you learn to work together didn't you
yeah oh yeah absolutely but it but it's
hard and it was hard yeah I would say
it's hard it uh you know we did have
some discussions but so it was the
biggest budget fight I would have to say
the biggest budget fight was right after
my company sold we had stock options so
we had some extra money coming from that
and I wanted some Bose headphones
because I work in a cubicle so there's
lots of people around all the time and I
really thought that I wanted that and
Jacob said absolutely not we're not
doing that those are really expensive
like a hundred and something dollars
yeah like three hundred oh my god so I
got turned down and that was that was
hard that was a good discussion for a
few days how did you and I think one of
the best things that's come out of the
this whole experience is not just paying
off the debt but the contentment that
comes along with that and just being
happy with what you have because now I
was telling Jacob yesterday I'm so glad
you told me know about those headphones
you know four or five months ago
whenever that was because I'm I'm fine
without having them now you know it's
it's just being content with what you
have and the Lord has really worked in
our hearts with that hmm it's a big deal
godliness with contentment is great gain
yeah very cool
well you guys are neat this
is very cool very fun so um what do you
tell people the secret to getting out of
debt is when they hear you guys are how
old are you 24 24 years old and you paid
off 93 thousand about your awesome when
they hear that they have to say these
words how did you do that what do you
tell them I'd say probably the biggest
thing would be to have an accountability
partner and that's we had each other and
we were able to bring each other down
back to earth just like with the Bose
headphones thing I had some things that
I've wanted to but she was there to
bring me back in accountability is a big
deal so that's good what about you
Jennifer what do you say the secret to
getting out of daddy is I would have to
say the budget we've had a couple of
people come to us since we've started
this journey because we're you know you
have to get on a budget and you have to
do this and listen to Dave Ramsey it's
going to change your life and the
budgets really been the very first step
for us there's a lot of things I think
that contribute to the success of being
able to get out and stay out of debt but
I think the budget is definitely where
you start there you go okay and it gives
you that common plan that you're working
together and creates that communication
in your ante but yes it helps the
accountability he was talking about you
know very cool way to go you guys I'm
proud of you this is awesome awesome
stuff man that's cool all right Jacob
and Jennifer Dallas Texas
$93,000 made off in 22 months 24 years
old making 90 now making a hundred
thousand between them count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
I love it I love it I love it that's how
it's done right there boom just like
that